pokemons world hello there I brought our
help okay
[Laughter]
Explorer cool beep oh hello place to
start it up to snap the whip Oh Indiana
Jones up in this [ __ ] Wow look at the
blood new computer totally worth it
we're happy wheels damn you I hope that
was you dying over there huh I can
understand every why everyone who play
that hates you so much son at all
God promise why didn't I get my balls
cut off died Mac all right yeah yeah oh
I am like the greatest air ever wise I'm
like super awesome oh that was a mistake
but I'm gonna make it Oh what what's
that winner loser winner loser loser T
why do I need a way 5 seconds oh is that
hurt
finally God takes us some madness oh I
feel a little mustache growing on your
face ba-bow we're gonna do better this
time
yeah oh let me go I didn't need that leg
maybe less aerodynamic ha angry mob
escaped
[Applause]
I didn't think fast and now isn't that
yeah that's what I thought it was dad's
a pony
that's a My Little Pony pony well hey
rainbow - whoa where you going where you
going where you going what are we doing
here what are we doing here Wow hey hold
on wait whoa really
Rainbow Dash calm down it's not worth it
come on okay calm down they don't
deserve to die oh man people really
don't like my little pony or they really
love my little pony I can't tell kinda
somehow I have no pretend those cookies
over there is impaled by his ding-dong
oh my jingle balls are hurtin okay space
grab gone hang on uh-huh I can't
contemplate the idea of doing this I can
do this come on give me the gun
yep gimme a little bra oh I get sick to
my stomach just thinking about shooting
people okay
try this again without being stupid can
we not be stupid go reset
I hate my life got it okay yep do it
yeah there we go worth it worth all the
pain and suffering but what is my life
become oh I got a flashlight hey you two
are the stills to book I'm Rob balls you
think you got the skills to block much
okay you think you got the skill there
we go what broke the backboard gonna get
mini okay here it's a note that's it 104
booth no no kill me ha ha ha ha ha
well now ha another note I'm soaked oh
no we all got problems made it I don't
remember that being in the original
Slender game yeah I don't remember
breaking wise either but I don't care at
this point
oh god oh god yeah yeah Oh mr. dick I
was gonna get it for you missed it you
[ __ ]
how epic are we talking here ooh there's
multiple levels of bottles Oh easy I
know I know I know I am but your mother
kid yeah that's right I hope you hold on
nope not hard not even a little bit hard
hard
Wow okay so you got to go real slow-like
guys just drift off the edge like a
mouse yeah look at me go Oh like Bob
well bah
ha what was that where was that why was
it that there you are mother [ __ ]
oh yeah kid Oh was not ready for that
one the kids did not use the arrow keys
at all so let's try the one with you
let's let go just let go man have faith
[Music]
faithful
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you like what you
saw and you want to see more why not
subscribe to my channel have a favorite
moment from the video write it in the
comments below thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye